hello and welcome to the new world
review your source for everything anime
and manga but I guess mostly hunter
hunter and today it's time to tackle a
question I've been getting quite
consistently actually ever since I began
making videos on modern hunter hunter
events and it's a very simple inquiry
which is where's gone I mean with all of
my talk about the succession war the
Dark Continent the future and indeed the
endgame of Hondo hunter in general I can
see why it might strike some people as a
little bit odd that our primary
protagonist doesn't even seem to warrant
a single mention well let's get into why
here now to begin we doing some context
and to achieve that let's cast our minds
back to the last time the gun was truly
relevant which would be the Chimera ant
hawk and as I'm sure we're all familiar
this was not exactly gone finest moment
as due to his profound anger sadness and
despair in regards to losing kite
Gaughan was able to invoke nen in a
truly terrifying way summoning up all
the power he would ever have and go on
to brutally kill Nephi Peto who
legitimately thought that this power
could have posed a threat to the Chimera
and king himself
pretty scary stuff however in order to
accomplish this goal made a dangerous
vow declaring that he did not care if
this was the end for him so long as he
used everything he had to kill Peeta and
at the very least he was successful in
that declaration becoming one of the
most powerful beings we've ever seen in
the series albeit temporarily and add an
exceptional cost and this for something
the Peter came to realize just prior to
their death
that gone had accomplished this by
essentially compressing his life taking
that natural gift he was born with and
being willing to throw it away and with
this of course the use of nen veto
hypothesized that gone would never be
able to invoke control of or again and
died happily knowing that gone would not
become a long-term threat to the king
but there was a lot more to the price
gone paid than this as it was directly
linked to how much of the power he used
during the skirmish which was not an
unsubstantial quantity following the
battle he immediately felt unconscious
and his body eventually withered into an
exceptionally unenviable existence on
the cusp of both life and death as such
when he learned the facts of the
altercation illumise ol dick went on to
describe the vow that Gahan had made as
accepting a fate even worse than death
but of course even though Honda hunter
does get quite dark at times this is
still a shounen and gone would be saved
from the state by best boy killer
rather dangerously invoking the powers
of nanika to allow go on to make a full
recovery
and when I say full recovery I mean it
only took away certain aspects of
Wow that gone had made which were the
effects on his body and his oral
lifespan however during the vowel gon
had also accepted the condition that he
would not be able to use nen again and
so that restriction remained even after
Nanak his actions and in this world nen
is a pretty damn important aspect of
survival which effectively cuts gone out
of the story going forward although I
should say that this is not necessarily
true there is definitely a path for gon
to return to prominence which came
courtesy of words from his father Jing
who claimed that he could still sense
Khan's aura when they met at the top of
the world tree which makes a lot of
sense because aura and lifeforce are
directly connected so forgotten to have
no aura would effectively kill him jinx
theory though is that GaN simply can't
see his aura anymore due to the crazy
vow he made which may imply that gone
might be able to reawaken it in the
future but there is no solid evidence to
suggest that this is possible and gonz
power to wield nen could certainly be
dormant for the remainder of his life
and that is essentially why gone is no
longer involved in current events
because he doesn't have the power to be
an asset anymore just a liability
although to be fair there's a lot more
to it than that because it's not like
Gaughan has a strong desire to visit the
Dark Continent so it's not like he's
being excluded from the story it's more
like Gaughan has made the decision to
remove himself from the action but even
if we accept it that yes this is a
shounen manga and the main character
should be involved anyway having him on
an expedition to the Dark Continent
probably isn't you know the wisest of
ideas even if he did still have access
to nen I highly doubt that the hunter
Association would have recruited him for
this mission I mean the people who have
been selected to go to the Dark
Continent are highly skilled incredibly
intelligent or otherwise absurdly
valuable in some way shape or form know
the descriptor of which is really ever
fit gone he is a pretty reckless being
and what has seen him through the series
thus far has been a mixture of natural
talent and the efforts of those around
him to keep him alive one way Gong could
have been integrated into things though
is if after meeting Jing he decided to
stay with him and became a part of the
beyond networ faction and headed to the
Dark Continent that way
however the manga did address the idea
of why gone did not choose to stay with
Jing and he himself said that if he'd
had access to aura then he would have
loved to travel with his father but at
the same time after completing his goal
of meeting him gone realized that Jing
wasn't really a father more like a cool
uncle and without access to aura there
was really no reason to stay with him
because he had other priorities in life
and this is very much the crux of why
gun is not involved in current events
the fact of the matter is that GaN
started this series but the simple goal
of finding Jing and
accomplish that goal it cost him
everything to do serve it he did it
so for gone to continue to be a
prominent figure in the series he would
need to find new goal because otherwise
there is really no compelling force to
feature him
for example the protagonists were
following through the succession war
arcus grafica and his goal is still
alive and well he's become involved in
the war to secure the remaining scarlet
eyes of the Kota clan and as a result
his extreme and driven actions are very
understandable and if going were to be
present in doing the same thing I think
it would be much less believable because
he has no investment in the succession
war or the Dark Continent for that
matter
in fact after finding Jing Gong doesn't
really know what to do with his life and
that's why he's returned to him to whale
island to kind of reassess and find a
new purpose in his lucky existence but
narrative Lee speaking this is a pretty
great ending to his story Honda Honda
can very comfortably continue without
gone and trying to shoehorn him in just
because he was the main protagonist for
the majority of the series can only hurt
the story going forward in my opinion in
fact the only way I could see Gong kick
into action would be receiving a
distress call from his friends once
they'd either made it to the dark
constant or the new continent even and
then perhaps he set sail with
killewarren some others for some kind of
rescue mission but other than that he's
in a good spot plus I feel like that
idea might just over complicate matters
because for that to occur we'd need a
second expedition and with just how
difficult it was said to be to put one
together I don't know if I see the
resources being pulled into another
voyage actually you know what that might
not be true because the Konkan empire
are constructing multiple black whales
as we speak so I have to admit there
there is always a maybe a big maybe but
I guess another thing to remember about
Honda Honda is that this really is not
your average Shonen as things began yes
this was a story Whitcomb was the
protagonist but over time and in between
long hiatuses hunter Hunter has evolved
into a story with at least four
characters capable of taking the helm of
the world at any given time five if you
include Hisoka and six if you include
Jing and I mention those last two
because I think that they're going to be
particularly important going forward I
mean in current events we've had seven
chapters in Aurora focusing purely on
the perspective of Hisoka
and when he does finally kick into gear
during the succession will arc or even
if he bites his time until the Dark
Continent then I suspect we're going to
be following his story a lot closer once
again and the same goes for Jing even if
in the grand scheme of things he may
have only been introduced recently he
carries the weight of a protagonist
behind him and he's still clearly
a hell of a lot of story to be told
Micah would not be surprised if King was
the focal point of the entire Dark
Continent arc if and when we eventually
get there because it does feel like
Korra pikas natural conclusion would be
during the succession wall so we will
probably need a new perspective to
follow plus that idea might also be a
nice book into the series
you know everything started on a quest
to find Jing so perhaps everything
should end with the man himself and who
knows what else could be thrown into the
mix as time has gone on hunter hunter
has evolved into something resembling
almost a game of Thrones style of
storytelling where we have various
points to follow through several key
characters I mean for example we could
also look at Cheadle in a protagonistic
manner as she is the focus of the
efforts of the hunter association in the
sack but it's not just the quote-unquote
good guys either because Honda Honda has
also really put us on the path of
blurring the lines between protagonist
and antagonist which was happening all
the way back in the orc new city arc and
was most certainly presence in the
Chimera ant arc and is also happening to
this day I mean another perspective to
follow a port black whale one is that of
the Phantom troupe who I've grown to
really like and somewhat rude for which
is bizarre considering the things
they've done but there it is another
more recent addition that could be
included into this discussion is 4th
Prince Arad Nick who I don't like per se
but he has an undeniably strong and
intriguing presence within the
succession war and we are very much
privy to his perspective in a much more
in-depth level than most of the other
princes and you know what we could also
throw a BL net row into this mix because
as much as I'd be tempted to class him
as an antagonist that simply isn't true
at this point in the story not yet
anyway and likes ride Nick he has this
incredible presence that is deserving of
primary focus and there are a bunch of
others as well because that is the
powerful world that Takashi has
painstakingly developed it almost
doesn't matter who we're following
because there are so many figures in
this world who are infinitely compelling
individuals so with no discernible goal
or driving force and with a wide range
of other characters more than capable of
holding our attention and want to pose
this question to all of you do you want
gone to return let me know in the
comments but for me personally I'd be
pretty alright if his story was done and
dusted I think that Gaughan has
undergone an incredible arc one filled
with a lot more hardship than most of
your average random protagonists and
when it came to reaching a breaking
point in regards to the whole kite
situation Gunn didn't pull out some
[ __ ] powerup that he'd have access
to going forward no instead he made the
decision to give up everything providing
us where they truly
tragic spectacle and really if he was to
return to the story with full
capabilities I think that would cheapen
his action significantly I really like
the Gold's decisions have had major
ramifications and even though he has by
and large brute forced his way through
this world of adventure there may not be
anything to pull him out of this one and
it's a consequence that he's going to
need to learn to live with
in fact he's lucky enough to be alive
and in condition to actually be able to
live a life at all and so as it seems go
only set to live out the rest of his
life as a regular boy which includes
helping out Mito with the housework and
of course 8:00 on a farm work it's
probably not the grandest of endings
version and protagonist so that's how to
Gashi as seemingly concluded gone series
arc and thus why he is not present in
current events but that pretty much does
it for this little explanation /
discussion on where's gone if you
enjoyed this video and the content the
channel produce in general then please
do consider donating to the new world
review patreon because the support of
all of your amazing people is what
continues to make this channel possible
and if patreon isn't quite your style
then please do leave this video a like
share or subscribe because it also helps
spoil this channel an incredible amount
and if you'd like to join the fun at any
time then please do head over to my
discord server where a wide array of
shenanigan takes place on a daily basis
and finally please do comment with your
thoughts and whether or not gone should
return to Hunter hunter this has been
the New World review and I'll see you
next time
[Music]